[Musica]
se vi chiedesse di chiudere gli occhi ed
immaginarvi nello spazio con gli occhi
rivolti verso la terra che cosa vedreste
io credo che la maggior parte di noi
adesso si sta immaginando qualcosa di
simile un bellissimo pianeta blu con uno
sfondo di stelle lontane
e se adesso vi chiedessi di avvicinarvi
man mano alla terra zoomando
quell'immagine che cosa vedreste
iniziereste a distinguere le acque dalla
terra riconoscendo i continenti e inizia
iniziando a percepire la presenza di
zone abitate e zoomando ancora un po di
più
inizia resta percepire dettagli vedreste
le auto le navi i ponti le strade in una
rete di infrastrutture ben disegnata che
è quello che ci permette di svolgere le
attività di ogni giorno
ecco io ora vi chiedo di fare invece
l'esercizio opposto quindi prendete
tutte le infrastrutture a quest'età
abituati e a cui potete immaginare e al
posto che collocarle qui sulla terra
dove sono proiettate le nello spazio
immaginatevi delle autostrade
interplanetarie che partendo dalla terra
arrivano sulla luna e arrivano fino a
marte
immaginatevi delle basi stabili sulla
luna e su marte e che sia normale
andarlo a visitare per un periodo di
vacanza per andare a trovare un amico
vostra figlia che lavora la e
immaginatevi che durante il viaggio voi
possiate fermarvi in una stazione di
servizio per fare rifornimento oppure
per fare una telefonata come fate sulla
terra
ecco molte di queste cose sembrano
fantascienza le sentiamo spesso
eppure realtà non sono così lontane come
potrebbe sembrare
e anzi già oggi la realtà ha superato
molte di quelle che sembrano solo
fantasie e ad esempio la logistica e
trasporto le infrastrutture nello spazio
sono già una realtà
io sono un ingegnere aerospaziale e
dirigo le operazioni appunto in
un'azienda che si occupa di logistica la
differenza che noi la logistica non la
facciamo sulla terra ma la facciamo in
orbita
avete presente le grandi navi cargo
quelle che arrivano al porto
arrivano al porto e scaricano le merci e
queste merci vengono consegnate a dai
corrieri che hanno il compito poi di
portarle porta a porta ecco noi facciamo
la stessa cosa solo che al posto che
consegnare pacchi noi consegniamo
satelliti tutti i satelliti che vengono
lanciati in orbita
servono per fornire la maggior parte di
quei servizi che usiamo tutti i giorni
no internet la possibilità di comunicare
anche dai posti più remoti della terra
l'osservazione della terra con il
monitoraggio degli incendi
dell'inquinamento degli oceani e tanto
altro ancora
ecco questi satelliti per poter
funzionare al meglio non è sufficiente
che vengano portati in orbita e lasciati
lì un po dove capita
ma come i pacchi che arrivano al porto
vengono smistati e consegnate a
destinazione anche questi satelliti una
volta portati in orbita dal cargo che
nel nostro caso è un razzo quindi
lanciatore hanno bisogno di essere
smistati ed essere portati in punti ben
precisi per poter funzionare al meglio
ecco nella mia azienda facciamo proprio
questo costruiamo dei satelliti più
grandi in cui imbarchiamo dei satelliti
più piccoli questi satelliti
vengono montati a bordo del lanciatore
del razzo che decollando supera
l'atmosfera è come una nave cargo arriva
al porto che nel nostro caso è lo spazio
ed è il nostro satellite poi aion in
orbit now che si muove sulle orbite
rilasciando e consegnando i satelliti
dove è necessario che vengano consegnati
per poter funzionare all meglio la prima
missione di questo tipo è stata nel 2020
e prima di allora non era mai stato
fatto niente di simile
e come tante delle cose che vi ho
raccontato all'inizio della
presentazione sembrava impossibile
effettivamente è stata una una grande
sfida perché io ho avuto la fortuna di
fare parte della squadra che ha seguito
un po tutte le fasi del progetto fin
dall'inizio dalla dalla prima idea fino
alla realizzazione al lancio alle
operazioni in orbita e fino al rilascio
dell'ultimo satellite dove doveva essere
posizionato il progetto iniziato nel
2017 e ed è stata davvero una sfida
perché allora eravamo circa una ventina
di persone con un'età media tra i 25 ei
30 anni
vale la pena dire che allora il mondo
spazio era molto diverso da come anche
solo e oggi era quasi esclusivo
monopolio delle agenzie spaziali e delle
grandi industrie spaziali e sembrava
impossibile che un gruppo di ragazzi
così giovani potesse fare qualcosa anche
solo di significativo sicuramente anche
perché eravamo in in italia quando penso
a quegli anni a me viene sempre in mente
questi quest'immagine l'immagine del
calabrone cioè quella leggenda per cui
si dice che il calabrone non dovrebbe
poter volare no troppo grosso troppo
pesante della forma sbagliata e così
eravamo noi eravamo troppo diversi
rispetto a tutto quello che aveva sempre
funzionato nel mondo spazio la fisica ci
spiega perché il calabrone può volare il
suo battito di ali è forte e veloce
fino a cinque volte più veloce di quello
del colibrì il calabrone può volare
perché con la forza e con l'impegno
compensa per quello che la natura non
gli ha dato e così abbiamo fatto noi
non ci siamo fermati alle difficoltà
avevamo una visione e l'abbiamo seguita
e così circa due anni dopo l'inizio del
progetto anche noi come il calabrone
eravamo pronti a volare
questa è un'immagine del della squadra
per cui questo è stato possibile eravamo
nella nostra krumm pronti per poter
inviare il satellite in base di lancio
ecco da quel giorno è iniziata una vera
e propria epopea nel senso che come
tutte le avventure niente è mai facile
da quel giorno abbiamo dovuto aspettare
almeno un anno prima di poter anche solo
iniziare la campagna di lancio
ci sono stati tanti ritardi il razzo che
doveva partire quello prima del nostro è
esploso in realtà esploso anche quello
dopo quindi abbiamo avuto una fortuna di
essere al posto giusto al momento giusto
ed è stata una grande fortuna perché noi
avevamo fatto all in con questo con
questo progetto non potevamo sbagliare
non potevamo permetterci che non che non
andasse bene
e finalmente a febbraio del 2020
abbiamo iniziato la campagna di lancio a
kourou in guyana francese
questa sono due immagini del nostro team
prima e dopo quella data che
riconoscerete quindi febbraio marzo a
cavallo dall'inizio della pandemia
quindi dopo aver aspettato un anno noi
siamo arrivati in campania abbiamo fatto
tutte le operazioni di preparazione del
satellite per chi fa il mio lavoro la
campagna di lancio il momento più bello
è quando si coronano mesi di lavoro e si
arriva alla base di lancio per preparare
il satellite installarlo sul razzo siamo
arrivati fino ad integrare installare
satellite sul lanciatore
ma poi appunto è scoppiata la pandemia è
tutto è stato fermato abbiamo dovuto
togliere il satellite dal lanciatore
togliere i satelliti che erano imbarcati
sul nostro e metterli in sicurezza
aspettando un lancio che non sapevamo
più quando sarebbe avvenuto a questo
punto la campagna di lancio è
ricominciata un'altra volta a questo
punto era maggio finalmente siamo
arrivati fino alla cronologia finale in
sala di controllo aspettando il 10 98
cronologia ferma per condizioni di meteo
avverse quindi c'erano dei venti in alta
quota che non permettevano di lanciare
in sicurezza abbiamo sperato che nei
giorni successivi il meteo migliorasse
non è successo a quel punto la finestra
di lancio era persa abbiamo dovuto di
nuovo tornare a casa ed aspettare
momenti migliori
finalmente a settembre 2020 siamo
arrivati alla fase finale questa è
l'immagine del nostro primo satellite
montato sulla struttura alta del
lanciatore insieme ai satelliti co
passeggeri di quel volo e qui a sinistra
subito le fasi successive alla
all'integrazione dei satelliti nel fair
ying quindi quel guscio che chiude i
satelliti sulla parte alta del
lanciatore ea destra vedete l'immagine
in cui questo assemblato viene portato
sulla rampa di lancio per essere issato
al di sopra degli stadi in cima in cima
al razzo ed ecco il 3 settembre del 2020
finalmente il lancio e io credo sia
stato il momento più emozionante di
tutta la mia carriera vedere qualcosa su
cui s'è puntato tutto su cui si è
lavorato per anni a spiccare il volo
verso il cielo colorando con colori
dell'alba del tramonto il crepuscolo di
una sera tropicale ed allora non ci
siamo più fermati
ora questi sono state liti che
costruiamo in in serie e questa è un
video ripreso a bordo di uno dei lanci
fatti il mese scorso questo è un
lanciatore falcon 9 di spaces e vedete
il nostro satellite che viene rilasciato
in orbita
e quindi consegnato in orbita il pacco
dal cargo siamo noi che prendiamo il
controllo ea questo punto ci spostiamo e
rilasciamo i satelliti a bordo questo è
un video ripreso a bordo del nostro lite
di uno dei satelliti ni che abbiamo
rilasciato in orbita
oltre a questo stiamo lavorando a
costruire un'infrastruttura che non sia
solo trasporto per rendere sostenibile
l'uso di un qualunque ambiente
necessario che ci siano infrastrutture
che ci sia logistica questo che stiamo
lavorando stiamo lavorando a servizi in
orbita quindi riparazione ispezione
rifornimento rimozione e in generale
tutta la comunità spazio sta lavorando
molto su questi aspetti anche alla
manifattura in orbita sarà realtà tra
una decina d'anni tutto quello che
abbiamo visto oggi sarà realtà entro 50
anni da oggi quindi chiudo con una frase
a me molto cara di margareth made che
dice non dubitate mai che un piccolo
gruppo di persone
se motivate possano cambiare il mondo
fare grandi cose
api farfalle calabroni ciascuno di noi
può grazie
[Applauso]